brazil's navy and army are helping the
federal police look for british
journalist dom phillips and his guide
indigenous expert bruno pereira they
were both in the javari valley a remote
indigenous reservation the size of
morocco when they went missing
the area is home to the world's largest
number of uncontacted tribes
pedera who knows the region intimately
sent an audio message on sunday saying
they were headed down the river to
atalaya
a small city two hours away from where
they were last seen
the indigenous expert has recently been
organizing expeditions with local tribes
training them to use satellite images
and cell phone apps to track down
illegal fishermen and poachers
we followed pereira in that same region
several months ago he told us then that
he had already received many threats
tribal leader beto marubo who has worked
closely with pereira says the illegal
fishermen and poachers work for criminal
drug cartels laundering their money
i can't imagine them being lost pedera
knows the region too well we think they
were ambushed violence in the javadi
valley and brazil's indigenous
territories in general has risen since
president jaya bolsonaro was elected
almost four years ago he's openly
defended the commercial exploitation of
protected lands and he's cut funding to
organizations created to protect them
pereira was still being threatened when
he was accompanying phillips who was
investigating the region for his book on
the amazon
when both men failed to arrive at
atalaya donati on sunday afternoon
native trackers started searching for
them fearing for their safety
the journalists brazilian wife and
english sister have made public appeals
to brazil's authorities
i want to make an appeal to the relevant
authorities to intensify the search we
still have some hope of finding him even
if i cannot find the love of my life
alive he must be found please intensify
the search
if anyone can help scale up resources
available for the search that would be
great
because time is crucial
brazil's president jaibo sonaro who is
up for re-election in october said both
men were on a dangerous adventure
anything can happen they could have been
lost or executed we pray they are safe
he said
former president louisiana lula da silva
who is running against bolsonaro tweeted
i hope they are found soon and are safe
and well
meanwhile in the javari valley the
search continues
yanakiv al jazeera